in the video on solubility I draw little
pictures of sodium and chloride ions
when sodium chloride dissolves or
disassociates into water this is sodium
and this is chloride and my simple brain
when I looked at it I said okay how
should I draw these things I said well
they're in the same period and sodium is
a group one element it's alkali it's an
alkali metal while chloride chlorine is
a is a halogen so chlorine is going to
have a smaller atomic radius and the
logic there just to review from the
atomic table trends is that they both
have both of their valence electrons are
in the third shell sodium only has 11
protons pulling in the center has 11 in
the center and it has only one electron
out there and it's in its valence shell
so the attraction isn't as strong as the
case of chloride which has 17 protons in
the center and then so it will although
it has more valence electrons it has
seven of them oh is that six seven the
set these protons are going to have a
stronger attraction on them and so the
if you just look at the trend in the
periodic table you would expect the
sodium neutral atom to be bigger than
the chloride neutral atom because this
guy has more protons pulling everything
in and that's how I drew the ions in
that video I said oh when I discipline
the water I'll have a big sodium ion and
a smaller chloride ion chlorine ion
which is incorrect because think about
and this was pointed out to me by one of
the viewers and and they are correct and
I should have realised this what happens
when you ionize these things
this guy will lose an electron right he
gives the electron to this guy so his
electron configuration is actually going
to look a lot more like neons he's now
going back he now will have no electrons
in that third shell in the third energy
state so now he's going to have an
atomic radius that's actually much more
similar to neons here right because he's
only he's going to have filled up the
second shell so actually the sodium ion
this is completely incorrect the sodium
ion is going to have an atomic radius
not that different than neon actually
it'll be even a little smaller than neon
because it has the same electron
configuration but it has one more proton
so the sodium ion is actually going to
be smaller because it gets rid of the
electron in the third shell and the
chloride the chlorine ion cation gained
an electron so it's completely completed
its third shell so here you have where
the chlorine ion is going to be bigger
so in that solubility video I should
have actually switched the places
between the sodium and the chlorine at
least in size-wise and of course you
know I showed how they disassociate in
water and you know this would be
attracted to the oxygen end of the water
and you know the hydrogen ends and all
that but although you can watch the
solubility for that video for that it
doesn't change the real take away from
the video but I think this is a really
interesting point that brings up that
you when you when you ionize these
neutral atoms it can significantly
change especially significant change
their relative atomic sizes anyway
hopefully you found that interesting